well California chef is now apologizing
after getting burned for saying he would
refuse service to customers who come in
wearing a mag aha the chef since
deleting the tweets after making a
threat where he also compared the hat to
a swastika and a white hood CNN hosts
talking about this issue last night
after claiming they don't support these
types of bands they then said this you
can refuse service you know no shirt no
shoes no service how is this any
different than the Baker with the cake
well that was about refusing service to
a group of people that should be a
protected class and unless you could
argue that Trump supporters should be a
protected class I don't think you have
much of an argument on that I don't want
to fall into the trap of underselling
the significance of the trigger of the
expression to people your clothing tells
a story about who you are what you think
about and what you represent that hat
means everything from I would say the
beginning of the campaign maybe even
before maybe that hat means the Central
Park five two people maybe it means
birtherism two people maybe it means you
know Mexicans are rapists of people or
maybe it just means make America great
again
Greg it's it's like they share one brain
it really is sweet
look we've talked about this before it's
a it's not really about a hat it's about
the expansion of a target by the media
and it is the media's responsibility
it's not it's not it's no longer about
Trump and it's no longer about voting
for Trump because if you're not part of
the resistance that's enabling you're
just like a stormtrooper right whatever
you're just like a Nazi if you're not
part of you know the thing is if it's
not about Trump it's not about a hat
it's not about voting anymore
it's about just any kind of extension to
Trump so they've widened they've widened
the target now so that it's a cultural
witch hunt you keep shaking your head
wand but we have so many examples of
this it's a cultural witch hunt for
anybody and it's sanctioned by people
like lemon to say okay if you're not
part of our group you're evil this is
really bad because you're demonizing
half the country okay so let me respond
and say the magg ahead to a lot of
people says if you're not part of our
group you're evil make it I think it is
a provocative State
now you know on the face of it I say
it's a piece of clothing and it's my the
fact that I view it as a provocative
peaceful why don't do that why do you do
that I think Don Lemon I think get the
idea to the eye so where did the idea
okay I want to know I'll tell you about
David Duke wearing it how about Caesar's
say acting people when they're driving
around the Trump truck holds you in a
racist drink orange juice do you not say
no more orange juice no but I'm saying
like gantry corn chair is a racist drink
or Chi no but I'm saying I thought they
made a very good point when they said
it's a protected class matter of
discrimination protected class is by
gender by sex by disability it's not by
political belief I'm ok with them said
you know the chef he's paying his price
that's that's the way the market should
work if you make a decision so it's a
free-market decision yes like Nike
saying we're back and Colin Kaepernick
right now they made it to say this guy
apologized by the way you know what he
apologized to apologize to the people
who work at the restaurant and whose
co-investment because it might cause
someone not to come to the restaurant he
didn't apologize for saying Magda had to
provide didn't he claims he's
apologizing he has the right not she
served people who doesn't want to serve
his restaurants a private business you
can do what he wants but Jesse he didn't
really apologize because he then went on
to say in his apology that the Hat
symbolizes anger hate and violence right
so you know it's like owning or not well
if Kanye came in rocking the Hat I
wonder if you'd serve Kanye West I think
he would and the difference between the
Baker deal I mean the Baker who's
Christian when you're asked to bake a
gay wedding cake and you're asked to say
you know you know God bless you know
dick and John and there's two guys in
the middle that he was arguing that you
then complicit in making a cake that you
know doesn't represent your Christian
values if you're just serving burgers
and fries you're not pretty nice of peda
forcing the chef to wear a magical
exactly it's a totally different analogy
and then you know as someone with the
authority on sweeping generalization of
course I think that what CNN is doing is
that to say that this hat represents
this to so many people permission to
make an analogy I would love to see if
you have
a New England Patriots hat to some
people that's gonna make that might
represent it's cheating and Spygate and
double homicide in Hernandez people
Jessie means him you know other people
that could just mean the Patriots and
winning so I think when when the this
country tells you don't wear this
clothes clothing drive this car stop
saying Merry Christmas baby it's cold
outside is about rape this is the reason
Donald Trump became elected because we
were so sick of people telling them what
to do how to think and what to say Dana
the media continues to allow these
comparisons to fly without any context
so they continue to say that it
represents a KKK hood without any
context about what the KKK actually did
and saying that a mag AHA is equal to
that and I feel like that downplay was
the severity of what the KKK was and
something that we've eradicated for the
most part in this country and not
something that we actually don't for
your books the sweeping generalizations
aren't necessarily just only Jesse's
specialty it's also another example of
why grown people should get off Twitter
and if you think that this is you're
gonna have to apologize to your partners
and your cross just like Twitter is
diminishing people's lives and we have
to all commit and get off at that yeah
we should we should kill this business
fraud but which is Lee I don't know what
they are using us we're not getting paid
to wait how am I gonna promote my show
you know be on Twitter no but on Twitter
that listens to any promos
in fact they hate the promotions really
very funny yeah it's like nobody likes
to be told